[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and Netflix have
just dropped the Dark Crystal
ager resistance season 1 the puppet show
pulls at your heartstrings throughout
and the outstanding season leaves an
ending that has a lot to unpack from it
throughout this video I'll be discussing
everything that you need to know about
the show as well as what could happen
down the line there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't seen the
Dark Crystal yet and don't want to know
what happens then I highly suggest that
you turn off now without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
my breakdown of the Dark Crystal Age of
resistance after the crystal of truth
becomes corrupted it spreads throughout
the land of draw infecting creatures and
inhabitants of the world we follow the
ghoul flings predominantly Ryan and DEET
as they fight to take down the Skeksis
and their leader the emperor in the
finale of the show we finally get a
showdown between the vulture like
creatures and the golfing's who have
been united throughout the first season
in order to save the land it's pretty
much all out war and when the general of
the Skeksis is betrayed and murdered by
the duplicitous chamberlain and the
collector is killed by dete it looks
like the ghoul flings might actually
have a chance
however the showdown isn't a simple one
and when the hunter comes back and
manages to destroy the jewel glade and
murders Mordor farrar it looks like the
day could be lost when he sets his
sights on Ryan in the last second now
Archer sacrifices himself and Hunter
dies with them as their two life forces
are tied together it's an awesome moment
that perfectly encapsulates just how
well the show manages to make you attach
to these puppets and for those who've
seen my spoiler free review of the
season in that I pretty much covered
just how well that the creative team
managed to merge the computer-generated
images in with the live-action ones
seamlessly it makes the final battle
outstanding and after the hunters death
it's left to the Emperor to kill the
rest of the resistance the villain goes
head-to-head with them but D is able to
force the Emperor's forces into a
retreat however this is at the cost of
using sanctuary tree magic which as we
see in the finale when rind
covers her has caused her to become more
infected by the darkening it's a really
bittersweet finale that perfectly sets
up another season and lets viewers know
that though they won the battle the war
isn't over just yet those who recall
episode a titled profits don't know
everything we'll remember that deets saw
a vision of herself sat on the throne
covered in darkness whilst Ryan was
trying to use the crystal of truth to
perhaps save her indicating that down
the line we might get some revelation to
this with the character being freed no
this isn't sentence stone in the wood
I'm sorry I couldn't resist that one in
the finale we did see that Bria found
the lost shard of the crystal of truth
and this pretty much confirms that the
visions in Episode II will probably be
the way that things pan out after the
title pops up we sort of get a post
credit title scene if you will which
shows that the Skeksis on down and out
just yet either and that the scientist
has created a new hybrid creature known
as the gotham which is a cross between
the grunick and Aerith on the giant
spider like crab creature could pretty
much change the course of the war and if
the gowling saw that they had it bad
already then an entire army of these
guys could quickly cause trouble for
them it sets up season 2 perfectly and
again cements that the victory may be
short-lived if this is what the war is
going to look like going forward fans of
the original movie will know that the
Gotham make a huge appearance in that
and it looks like the show is slowly
starting to tie together with the film
in the movie the Skeksis pretty much
wipe out the majority of the gulling and
going off that it looks like the
villains may be the winners come the end
of season 2 especially with any weapons
the Gulf Fling have no idea what's in
store for them and I really think that
come next time we will pretty much see
them being wiped out left right and
center with a lot of our favorite
characters dying before making it to the
time that the film takes place either
way it definitely seems to be tying
things together nicely and it will be
interesting to see if they do line up
with the film or if they go off in their
own direction as for the Emperor if you
don't want any spoilers about the dark
crystals film or the characters
themselves then turn off in 3 2 1
we still here good he dies during the
movie so it seems like you will be
sticking around for the foreseeable
future too
overall there's a lot to look forward to
and I definitely recommend that you go
and check out the film if you're
desperate ill in the fates of the
characters going forward obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the Dark
Crystal as well as what you hope to see
in season two are you gonna go check the
movie out now or do you want to stick
with the show until it's time comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my spoiler free
review of the doc crystal which you'll
be linked at the end if you want to come
talk to me about movies TV shows games
and comic books then you can follow me
on twitter at definition whitey it's the
best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see
you over there after this also just want
to let you know that we're giving away a
free copy of John wick 3 and blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
Dark Crystal in the comment section
below the winner will be chosen at
random on September the temp that the
blu-ray will be shipped out from then to
ever get surprised it's the best of luck
to everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
[Music]
you